without any further delay I will
introduce to you Michael Seibel the CEO
of Y Combinator the founder of companies
like justin.tv and twitch and Socialcam
to begin what is going to be a deep dive
into product over the next several
lectures
Michael so before I begin its kind of
had a conversation with Jeff and I and I
wanted to say a couple of things about
my experience at justin.tv and and
twitch so what I will say is that we
broke many if not all of the rules that
are about to tell you at various points
during our company the things that
allowed us to survive were one our
founding team was extremely technical
Justin Emmett and Kyle all were amazing
to work with and basically what I found
amazing about them is they were not
intimidated by any technical challenge I
think that I would not be standing here
if I wasn't
privileged to work with them and so I
think this is something that a lot of
companies a lot of startups a lot of
sort of founders don't truly understand
like that fact allowed us to break a lot
of rules the second is we didn't spend a
lot of money we moved out when we were
21 22 22 and 23 we lived in a
two-bedroom apartment that apartment
cost $2,500 a month we were each given
$500 a month walking around money which
technically is against the law because
it was below minimum wage but who cares
about laws and that was it that that was
the game
Emmett got his own bedroom Kyle and
Justin slept in bunk beds I slept in the
living room and sometimes on the balcony
we just didn't spend
much money that gave us a lot of ability
to screw up and make mistakes and then I
say the last thing that was kind of
interesting I only realized later is
that our ego was highly tied to our
startup we were not doing a startup to
have a cool resume item it was really
the only thing we had done on our own
and so I think at various points during
the company when it looked like we would
fail basically our startup failing was
our life failing right it was like well
this is the only thing you've done so
far and so if it fails you get F on life
and I think that we all had that feeling
very internally and therefore we just
couldn't really conceive of giving up so
I think more than anything I want to say
in the rest is presentation those were
the three things that saved our company
made our company work and strangely I
don't even think if you take one of
those things away any one of them we
would have died so this isn't one of
those things where it's like oh you can
grab for one or two and that's pretty
good we needed all three or else game
over so as I get into product I'm gonna
tell stories from justin.tv from really
early days at which when I was still
there and then also from a YC company
from a couple batches ago named poppy
it's a company that I've advised since
so invested in did YC great founder name
off knee and weirdly I just feel like I
needed to do a case study outside of my
own story somehow it's gonna help share
these lessons a little better so I
always like to start with what problem
are you solving because when I'm pitched
by founders most often they just want to
tell me what their idea is what they're
gonna do what their product does I think
what's interesting is that like
oftentimes they don't even know why they
don't know what's the problem that they
expect to be solved at the end of what
they're doing now I think that for some
businesses is totally fine
right I think that especially if you're
early on especially if things are still
in project phase whatever but I think at
some point pretty early on you have to
figure out
what are we doing and what do we expect
the result to be so at justin.tv the
first thing the problem we were solving
was entertainment we were making TV
shows Justin was the first one broadcast
his live 24/7 this was to be a TV show
so actually pretty easy for us to
understand whether that was working or
not is anyone watching right that's the
problem we were solving people watch TV
shows no one was watching so we didn't
solve the problem then when we pivoted
to an open platform the problem became
can we let anyone broadcast live but
that was problems trying to solve anyone
can broadcast live on the Internet and
once again once we understood that it
was very easy for us to judge whether or
not someone could do it we had this open
platform as anyone using it but I think
that like that was key to what we were
doing and then sometimes when I talked
to founders there's something they want
to do in the world there's a problem
that they're kind of vaguely interested
in or there's an idea that are vey
interesting but they really haven't
nailed down what's the actual problem
we're solving if you don't know the
problem you can't know whether you
solved it
the first thing I asked founders can you
state the problem clearly in two
sentences if you can't you don't know
the problem right in fact it's really
only take you one sentence so if someone
asks you a problem you're solving and
you find yourself delivering an essay
you're doing it wrong
- have you experienced the problem
yourself this is not always required but
is certainly helpful I've met a lot of
founders who are trying to solve a
problem for someone else who they've
never met never talked to and don't
truly know whether that person exists in
the world and so all things being equal
this is a great hand that you're on to
something well at least one person has
had this problem before the next one's
can you define this problem narrowly
what's interesting is when you get
started you can't really solve this
problem for everyone who has it
so when justin.tv first started we
couldn't let anyone broadcast live video
you had to have a laptop you had to have
go to internet connection you had to
have a webcam there are all these kind
of things you needed and so can we
actually now talk about all right we
want to make live video for everyone
but let's talk about the people that we
can address first who can we help first
and I think oftentimes founders kind of
want to skip that step they want to
solve the mega problem like I want to
cure cancer I'm only talking about when
everyone's cured as opposed to like what
can we address immediately how do we get
the first indication that this thing is
working and then the last one is the
problem solvable so here's what I'll
bring up with poppy so poppy is a
company that's essentially uber for
babysitting they make it really easy for
babysitters I'm sorry for parents you
need babysitter's to get babysitters
poppy is a very interesting company
because you need babysitter's for a lot
of different types of things some people
need a babysitter five days a week while
the parents at work right that looks a
little more like a nanny some people
need a babysitter whether it's an
emergency
oh I have you know I have a medical
emergency and I need a babysitter right
now because I need to go to the hospital
some people need it because there was
miss planning oh I thought well housing
was gonna be at this time and it wasn't
I thought I was gonna be here this time
it wasn't I need a babysitter some
people need a babysitter because they
have an infant right and so this baby
students have a bunch of skills some
people need a babysitter to watch their
15 year old to make sure they don't get
you know out of the house different
skills and so what's interesting is that
if you just start with oh we're gonna
help people get babysitters it's not
really good enough to understand what
you can address right away right which
one of those use cases do you want to
address if you were to state the problem
more narrowly though let's say we wanted
to start out with infants right we want
to make it easy for parents to get
babysitters for infants then we can
really ask the question is the problem
solvable I think one of the things that
poppy discovered when operating their
business is that the level of skill that
you need for a parent to trust you with
their infant when they haven't met you
is very very high so the idea that
you're going to have a rotating set of
people you haven't met watch your little
baby hard very very hard they have to be
very skilled and then on the flip side
uber model only works because there's a
whole bunch of basically replaceable
people with a common skill well it turns
out the people who've got the skills to
watch infants and make parents
comfortable with that tend to have nanny
jobs where they work lots of hours and
tend to be paid fairly well especially
in up-and-coming cities and so now we
have this disconnect where it's like
well we want to solve the problem of
infant watching for moms but that talent
pool who can solve the problem the
supply of babysitters they might not
exist problem might not be solvable and
so going through this exercise in real
time like with your products out in the
world you should be thinking about these
things you should be thinking how have I
narrowly defined the problem I want to
solve first and you should be always
asking yourself is it actually solvable
I think a lot of founders just don't
want to think about this because it's
hard it's hard to think about who you
want to talk to first it's hard to
understand oh maybe I can't solve that
problem I have to move on Abney was a
mother of two kids and she was really
pissed she couldn't solve this problem
because it was her problem but it's
turned out to be very very hard problem
to solve you know young infants
on-demand babysitters all right the next
question I always ask is who is your
customer and really you don't understand
the problem you're solving until you
understand who you're solving it for a
lot of times people just want to say
everyone everyone's the customer right
and that seems like it makes sense in
some cases right if you're building a
social network or a search engine right
everyone uses those things now what I
will say is that in almost all of the
products that everyone uses now there
was a time when almost no one used them
and the creators of those products had
to figure out who is the ideal first
customer and so if you don't have a good
answer to this question you're gonna be
lost do you have no idea who you should
talk to to ask them whether this problem
has been solved and you have no idea who
to talk to to figure out who this
product is for and I'd be surprised the
number of founders who are just building
something as if
they were writing a creative novel where
it's just a product of their own brain
and no interaction with anyone on the
outside and it's not even problem that
they're solved that they've experienced
themselves don't do that don't be one of
those founders like you can talk to your
users you just have to figure out who
they are the next question I often ask
is how often does your user have the
problem what's so surprising is when you
talk through startups with people
sometimes they choose problems without
quite understanding who the user is or
the frequency of the problem so give you
an example a lot of people will come to
YC and a popular idea back in the day
was to build a car shopping website now
if you guys have been on car shopping
websites especially about five years ago
they all basically suck they're they're
hard to use they're not very transparent
you kind of want to have this almost
Tesla experience of just buying a car
but they never actually work out that
way
and what's interesting is that like a
lot of founders come back to this
problem
over and over and over again and they
always think that their customer is the
person buying a car now the reality is
is that when you go buy a car assuming
it's not a complete lemon you typically
keep that car for seven years so what
happens if I told you I'm going to
create a start-up and if I home run with
my customer if my [__] customer loves
me they're gonna come back seven years
from now that's hard it's very hard it
turns out a lot of the car buying
websites are not built for the person
who's shopping for car because that
person doesn't have a problem very often
they're actually built for the person
who's selling a car that person has a
problem every day every day the
dealership has to hit their numbers and
so you don't see as a customer how that
product helps the real customer the
person who's trying to sell cars and so
by doing this analysis I really try to
push founders in understanding who is
getting the most value out of this
product and it's really helpful if
you're trying to help someone with the
problem they have frequently
if you think about the products that you
use on a daily basis they tend to be on
the front screen of your phone you tend
to use them without even thinking they
become almost extensions of you if you
think about apps that you've installed
and then they're kind of on the third
page in the back or they're buried on
the second page is some folder those
tend to be the ones you don't use very
often hopefully they don't need you to
use them very often or else they're
probably not very good businesses the
next question I always ask is how
intense is the problem I find a lot of
founders think they have a good idea but
they don't do this frequency and
intensity analysis and so if you have
both an infrequent and low intensity
problem that you're trying to solve
you're gonna have a problem getting a
lot of customers even interested in
talking to you um all things we go if
you graph problems it's nicer for them
to be higher intensity higher frequency
let's think about a company like uber
for example usually when you are
somewhere and you need to go somewhere
else it's a pretty intense problem I
have to go to work I have to go to the
doctor I have to go pick up my kids
they're so intense you might have bought
like a twenty thousand dollar car to
help you do those things right so it's
an intense problem and then when you
think about frequency how often do you
move more than a mile more than walking
distance every day happens a lot and so
if you think about that even though you
look at the taxi market and you say ah
taxis unit before Hoover taxis that's
not that big of a market if you just
look at the customer you say high
intensity problem that happens very
often there's probably a good business
here the last one is are they're willing
to pay so many founders who come into YC
their first thought is completely wrong
on this front their first thought is I
need to give it away for free because
that's the only way I'm gonna get users
one of the things that I always push
them to do is think about it this way if
you want to know whether you have a good
product it's a lot easier to make it a
little bit harder for your users to use
it and then see if they use it anyways
because if I am
really intense problem and you say well
it's gonna cost 100 bucks for the person
with extremely tense problem they
probably think that's a deal if you have
extremely and if you don't have
extremely tense product problem you
charge zero dollars you can have a bunch
of users who come in who don't really
have the problem but they're just trying
something out if you try to learn from
them on how to improve your product
oftentimes they'll lead you astray so
strangely starting with a higher price
or a price is almost always better than
starting free almost always better and
if you have to start free you need to do
this analysis of how do you talk to the
users where the problem is actually
intense I talk to the users who are
using a product frequently in production
for real-world purposes as opposed to
the hobbyists talking your customers is
good but talking to the wrong customers
very very very bad I've seen a lot of
companies that are basically hijacked by
bad customers especially companies where
there's real-world costs so for example
you know if you have a company like
poppy there's real-world costs in
recruiting managing and working with all
of these baby sitters and if you have a
company if you have a customers trying
to basically take advantage of that
system being laid being non-responsive
being rude to the baby sitters that's
not going to help you run your business
and you'd be surprised at how many
hijack customers there are out there the
last question I always ask people is how
easy is it for your customers to find
because inevitably you're gonna need to
reach them and what's interesting I look
at the the last batch there are two b2b
companies one b2b company was here in
America and it was very easy for them to
find customers they could basically go
to LinkedIn find their customers on
LinkedIn find the name addresses email
them they get email thousand customers a
week another company doing b2b was in
China and interesting enough reaching
out over email and the b2b context in
China just isn't - well done practice
getting access to people's email
addresses is actually not very hard not
very easy and so strangely they had this
challenge of a relatively simple
business to explain a real intense
problem that happened often if they had
no way to reach their customers
and to basically invent new ways to do
it and so I often want to ask this
question because if your customers are
ridiculously hard to find
you better have a solution for that
upfront you can't build the whole thing
and expect for them to find you and so
often times you had a situation where
someone's trying to build a product for
either an imaginary customer or a
customer who can't really hope to use
the product I'm trying to get water to
people in the middle of a desert in the
Sahara all you need to do is download my
app and go online and then they can put
their GPS location and then we'll
deliver water to them that's not gonna
work but you'd be surprised at how many
people just don't think through those
logical steps all right next up does
your MVP actually solve the problem that
you want to solve this one is so
hilarious how often it comes up because
in the process of building an MVP things
just go weird and squirrely so you had
this problem and then you started
building it and then you talked to other
users and then before long you're
launching something and then you realize
it doesn't actually do the thing that
you promised and even the thing that you
want to do so part of your process of
building the MVP it's really helpful to
do these pre steps first it's really
really really helpful because then you
can always gut-check yourself on am I
actually solving the problem the other
thing is that it's really helpful to
build your MVP quickly typically the
longer it takes the more you're gonna
have MVP and problem drift or customer
drift if you decide to only build your
MVP in two weeks it's a lot easier to
stay on task and make sure actually
solving that problem for that customer
the way you test this by the way is you
give your product to customers like you
you have to do that that is a required
step what I find interesting is that a
lot of people think of their product as
a painting as something that could be
appreciated as a piece of art as
something that even if it's appreciated
by one person is special that's not what
you're making products are not paint
they're not art if users don't find
products useful then the products are by
definition not useful and they're a
waste of your time to build and I think
a lot of people want to be artists the
startup world is very unforgiving to
artists and I think that interestingly
after the fact a lot of people are
painted as artists right like Steve Jobs
is painted as this like magical artist
right and the other day he had to figure
out how to get make a phone that
millions of people would buy if only one
person bought the iPhone he would be
seen as a failure so the definition of
art is it only has to be appreciated by
one or maybe even none that's not the
appreciate that maybe just the Creator
that's not the definition of a
successful product so this is what you
should always be got checking does every
piece solve the problem the number one
problem with this question is that it
hurts the answer hurts you're gonna find
that a lot in startups where the answer
hurts you know doesn't solve the problem
but as long as we don't talk about it
maybe nobody knows it doesn't solve the
problem a lot of the answers inside of
startups are feel that way which
customers should you go after first a
lot of founders are very confused by
this question what I find interesting is
just like the instinct is to go after
customers by making the product free for
some reason I find a lot of people think
that their instinct should be to go
after the hardest customers first almost
as if it's like a proof like if I can
get this impossible person to use
something then like it'll be easier I
know that I've made something good I
like to start from a different point
it's an MVP you know you've made
something bad like that's the definition
of MP it's bad so the real question is
like how do you find people who are
willing to use a bad product right there
have to be the most desperate the most
desperate and so a lot of times I talk
to founders I really pushed them towards
who are the most desperate customers and
how do you talk to them first that's
what I define as easy desperate if
you're having like a you know if you're
trying to sell a simple piece of
software to someone
thousand dollars a month and you're
engaged in a six month conversation with
a company that's not a desperate company
move on in fact when you're doing
enterprise sales early as a start-up
like you're looking for even more
desperate customers just because
literally takes so long to sell them so
if you don't feel like you're dealing
with desperate people if you feel like
you've dealt you're you are trying to
get impressive customers who aren't
desperate you're probably doing it wrong
literally the number one thing I often
tell found is just like whose business
is gonna go out of business without
using you which people out there are not
going to be able to get to work or to
watch their kids how do you find the
people who are just literally are
screaming for something like this and
then how do you talk to them and not
talk to your friends I had a bunch of
friends who were using social cam right
my company was doing video for for
sharing with friends and they weren't
really using it they were using it
because it was like my app and there
were friends with me I literally had one
friend it was like super honest about
this Steve the CEO of Reddit when we
sold Socialcam he literally said thank
God now I can delete this app from my
phone so the perfect definition of
someone you should not be trying to get
product feedback from right and so he
didn't have the problem we were solving
many of your friends won't have the
problem that you're solving make sure
you find D and by the way the kind of
community of start-up people and/or
investors usually don't have the problem
that you're solving so if you're using
investors as a trigger for am i solving
the right problem or like do they find
this useful it's almost never the case
almost never the user of a product that
comes into I see and so ignore your
investors ignore your friends like they
will lead you 100 percent astray out of
good intentions they'll try to be
helpful well at you know I've never
lived in the Sahara I've never been
thirsty but maybe it should work like
this right live like horrible run away
run away once you start having customers
I think it's a very helpful exercise to
try early to identify
by bad customers these are people who
are blasting your support these are
people who are constantly
constantly complaining
my co-founder Justin he had a company
that was basically on demand personal
assistant and he was the first one who I
met who actively fired a customer is
basically uber for personally support
systems called exact and literally a
customer would have the exact do
something like like crazy like something
you couldn't do right like we organized
my house the way I want things organized
and I'm not gonna tell you I want them
organized or go shopping for me but I'm
gonna critique every single like piece
of fruit and vegetable that you picked
out she was like completely unrealistic
expectations and so after refunding the
person four times for four different
tasks the person did a fifth task on the
product right because he's getting a
bunch of value for free and Justin Cosmo
says you're fired you can't ever use
product again like look for those people
because if you aren't delivering
anything of value there will be people
trying to exploit that value and some
might be doing it not out of the
goodness of their heart so don't let
these people lead you astray we talked
about this don't discount now here's a
caveat on discounting Parker from
zenefits came to I see a couple years
ago and he gave this great talk about
enterprise sales and zenefits his
product that's given away for free so
it's actually kind of a interesting
enterprise sale and one of the things he
said that really got to me was that
there are ways to convince organizations
basically you can structure discounts
and incentives into your sales pitch if
you basically understand what value are
getting back so his example was he would
try to sell to a company to switch on to
zenefits for their health care and he
would say look because of this third
party let's just say AWS has given us a
discount who knows why right we just
bought dedicated instances so now
we have 40 percent lower AWS bills so we
can actually pass on some benefit to you
but only for the next 30 days now I feel
horrible even telling you this because I
want you to take as much time as you
need to buy my product I would just hate
if you bought it on the 31st day and I
couldn't give you this discount now this
isn't a let me give this away for free
like because I'm afraid people won't use
it this is a very structured process
that he did he basically incorporated a
deadline based on some third party
providing a benefit to the customer and
he knew that when he said this to the
customer every time that this was talked
about internally the deadline would be
brought up and the discount would be
brought up and suddenly this has now
become not a way to be afraid right - oh
I'm not sure how many customers minutes
make it free became a way to speed up
the process and his discount was just
baked in like he just priced the product
15% higher so it's like literally like
that is the way to do it
the way not to do it is I'm afraid no
one's gonna use it so I have to talk not
charge any money okay
the next is how to set up metrics how
many of you are using Google Analytics
as your primary metrics products raise
your hands okay you are doing it wrong
yes so setting up metrics is something
that's like super important very early
in your company because it's how you
know whether your product is being used
or not and it's one of the number-one
sources of new product ideas and
inspiration so Google Analytics I would
say is a great product for knowing how
many people came to your website today
and how many pages they viewed which
used to be relevant and it's not really
relevant anymore and where they came
from
um what it's not a great product for is
identifying what people's actions were
when they were using your product did
they click this button did they see this
screen how long were they on the page
for before they did something else did
they leave something in their cart for
all of those things you want an events
based metrics product
Mixpanel amplitude heap I think we've
funded like 50 of them they're like 100
of them out there you should be using
one of them if you're not you can't be
sophisticated at building your product
this is just kind of a prerequisite so
get on it and this goes back to the
early thing that I mentioned which is
technical teams for a technical team
implementing Mixpanel is ridiculously
easy for a non-technical team it's
basically impossible this is just one of
the many advantages of having a highly
technical team you actually know what
users are doing without this you're just
missing a huge part of what you need to
know the next thing and Suhail from
Mixpanel gave a great talk about how do
you set up mix panel one of the
challenges of setting up mix panel is
the second that you're sitting there
saying I want to track what my users are
doing you can come up with like 150
things your users can do with your
product and you want to track all of
them that's often a mistake if your
analytics product is got too many
analytic sitting in it in the beginning
it will be hard to use and part of what
you're doing if you've never used
product like links panel before is
learning how to use it and most
importantly teaching your employees and
your co-founders how to use it because
this product should be a product that
everyone in your company understands how
to use is everyone your company should
understand how the product is
functioning this is not something that
like the CTO uses and creates reports
from this is interactive product that
everyone can use
so to start pick five to ten simple
stats
let's take Instagram as an example right
if I went to pick five to ten simple
stats for Instagram let's say open the
app trade in an account took a photo
applied any effects share the photo
that's probably all I need in the
beginning right I mean the number one
mechanism for Instagram is taking a
photo and sharing it I can track that
I'm pretty happy the other thing that I
will warn you about is that if your
product is good the naming conventions
for these stats are going to become very
important because one day there will be
a hundred or even a thousand stats you
track so think a little bit ahead of
time and don't name something something
that only you'll understand make sure
that you if your company's good many
many people have to look at the
stats make measurement a part of your
product spec oftentimes when I talk to
founders they say we built it on this
release and we'll add the measurements
some point in the future I don't
understand how that works you build
something you want people to use but
you're not incorporating the measurement
that tells you whether people are using
it that doesn't work building
measurement is part of a product spec so
when you spec out a product you better
spec the stats you expect to be tracking
and you should also spec the stats that
you think are going to improve when
you're building that product that should
be part of the spec it should be part of
the first release otherwise you're
flying behind and this is just countless
times a justin.tv this is screwed us
okay
part development cycle so justin.tv was
and twitch was three yell kids and one a
mighty kid yell probably the most
productive skill you're taught is how to
argue with other yell kids and so the
number one way to get products developed
at justin.tv was to win an argument with
the three yell kids
kyle disliked this so much that he
actually switched his sleeping schedule
so that he wouldn't have to be involved
in these arguments so we were awake from
about 8 a.m. to about 12 midnight he
would wake up around 11:00 midnight and
write code all night and then go to
sleep in the morning so he wouldn't have
to argue with us on what stupid thing to
build one of the classic arguments at
justin.tv that lasted approximately
three months was the background color
for the original site so the original
site is just one page Justin wanted a
black background I wanted a wood grained
background three months of bait we
settled on changeable backgrounds so
there were five background options
clearly idiotic like I said we made many
of these mistakes um we didn't actually
really learn how to do product
development cycle until we failed at it
for about five or so years
and during that time this is what bad
product-moment cycle looks like one we
would release every three months for a
web only product that is horrible second
we would have a product meeting and we
wouldn't write anything down right it
was just four of us can't you remember
you're an idiot if you can't remember a
conversation before people had right and
if you forget something just ask one of
the other four people in the room right
No so as a results during the first
month of the dev cycle we'd all go off
working on slightly different versions
of the thing we wanted to build because
we didn't write down this back then at
the end of that month we'd come together
and we'd be like oh wait this isn't
we're not really building all the same
thing and then we'd have another product
meeting where we didn't write anything
down and go off and build again for
another month at this point right two
months in we probably have about three
weeks of productivity and about five
weeks of just stuff that's gonna have to
be thrown away at this point in we kind
of come back together and realize that
we're not 2/3 of the way done through
this sprint were less than 1/3 of the
way done and we're starting to get sick
and tired of this feature that we're
building so then we basically say
alright slash-and-burn
let's just make a shitty version of it
and we take another month to do that now
we've worked on this product for three
months if you had any good or new or
interesting ideas during that three
month period of time you were told we're
already working on something else so
your ideas are worthless just write them
down somewhere
whatever we're working on this thing
right now at the end of the three months
instead of wanting to iterate we were
sick of the da TM feature we just spent
three months building poorly so we would
launch it and if it wasn't used right
away we would come up with some new
brainstorm on some brand new feature
that would rescue the company this is
the wrong way to run a company it was
absolutely horrible I was talking to
Jeff earlier the major product decisions
that justin.tv made that carried through
to twitch - today was chat on the right
video on the left we decided that in
2006 it is the same way 2018 the vast
majority of the products issues we made
were
and never saw the light of day because
they went through a process like this so
if your process revolves around arguing
revolves around not writing speck
revolves around long dev cycles you are
doing it wrong you are 100% doing it
wrong what I'm gonna give you is a model
of how we figured out how to solve the
problem steal as much or as little of
this as you want but understand that if
you have any of the symptoms I'm talking
about you need to solve them or else
your company is just going to be much
less productive than it could be first
you need to actually have a number that
you track that reflects how good your
company is doing almost always if you
ever are going to charge money to your
customers this number should be revenue
almost always if you are never going to
charge your customers money like
Facebook then maybe it should be a usage
based metric like how often do your
customers come back every day like DEA
use it is almost always one of those two
usage if you will never charge the
customers money if you will charge the
customers many people will invent
reasons why these two metrics don't
apply to their business one percent of
them might be right 99 percent of them
are probably wrong
whatever this KPI goal is make sure
you're measuring it make sure that
everyone in your company knows what this
goal is every day helpful to put it on
some screen somewhere if an investor
asked you what your KPI is you not only
should be able to say what it is
sheíll to say what the metric is you say
where the metric is now where it was
three months ago where it was when you
started this is kind of table stakes the
next thing that we would do is as the
kind of product person I would come into
the meeting and I would say this is the
KPI we're looking to improve this this
cycle at Socialcam the top level KPI was
da use and the three ways that we
thought we contributed to da use was
either new users retention of users and
new content created those three things
so every cycle we ran one of those three
numbers moving that number so that the
right direction was the goal and we'd
run an open brain
brainstorm for us would take a couple
hours and it was a real brainstorm it
wasn't the brainstorm we're like you say
what about this and your co-founder says
that's a dumb idea that's not a
brainstorm
the real brainstorm is that any idea
that's stated is written on the board
the cool thing about these brainstorms
is that everyone's computers were always
open to Mixpanel
so if you had an idea or you had a
thought you could always just go in and
check the metrics and see like oh is
that right or is that wrong you'd be
surprised at how much value there is and
seeing your idea on the board not
everyone's gonna get to have built what
they want to have built but the fact
that your idea was considered and added
to the board actually makes people feel
a lot better than otherwise people feel
horrible when their ideas are shot down
CEOs their job is to make their
employees not feel horrible all the time
sometimes I think CEOs think their job
is to shoot down ideas it's not it's not
gonna help you at all I mean everyone by
the way in our company participated in
this brainstorm at that point that was
for people so easy to do the next thing
was we did what's called easy medium
hard
so our brainstorm was actually typically
split up into three categories new
features or iterations on existing ones
bug fixes and/or other maintenance and
tests a B tests we want to run we have a
whole board filled out with ideas on
these three categories and then we go
through and do what's called easy medium
hard for us hard mint it would take one
engineer most of the dev cycle to build
medium typically meant to take a day two
days easy means we could do multiple in
a day this is extremely important how
many of you in this room do not know how
to write code raise your hand there we
go I am one of you it's extremely hard
if you don't know how to write code to
figure out whether your idea is easy to
build or hard to build that's something
that you actually learn as a skill over
time and this process basically is the
process that can help educate you it
turns out that easy ideas get built way
faster way more quickly than hard ideas
and it turns out that most hard ideas
can be restated as an easy idea if you
just understand what
bits of your heart idea are both useless
and hard and most of the time there are
useless and hard bits and hard ideas
that can just be removed and so for us
this was educating everyone the team and
for us we had a cross-functional team so
someone might not realize that this is
really hard on the video system it might
be an easy web feature but hard on the
video system or vice versa so this was
basically educating everyone a team on
what's easy medium hard it also created
an objective standard by which to start
thinking about these ideas instead of
just based on the argument ability of
the person delivering them it was like
well your idea is like really freaking
hard and seems like it wouldn't move the
numbers that much based on Mixpanel
whereas like this other person's idea is
super easy and probably can move numbers
a lot the next thing we would do is we
decide hard first so we look at all the
Harz and we say which hard is gonna
impact the KPI the most and then we move
to Easy's and then we move to one with
moved at mediums and then we moved to
Easy's what was interesting is that like
just with the ideas on the board and
with easy medium hard a lot of the ego
was removed from the debate because one
you knew your idea has been considered
and two you'd sent some objective
measure about how hard it was and three
because the board has a bunch of ideas
on it now it's probably pretty easy for
you to find an easy idea that you really
like and so you're just gonna be excited
that that's probably gonna get in and
you're really hard idea that's fine if
it doesn't the next step is you have to
write the spec this is where everyone
[__] up the meeting might be going on
for four hours now and this is the step
no one likes you actually go through and
you actually write down what do we mean
by we're adding video filters to
Socialcam what do we mean by were
allowing people and justin.tv and twitch
to chat with one another what does that
actually mean how is it going to work
this is really important and once this
is done you can then distribute tasks to
the team now we would run these cycles
every two weeks at Socialcam because
back then summing to the AppStore took
longer if you're doing a pure web
product you can run these cycles once a
week the rule that we had to make the
team not hate these really
meetings is the only meeting we had this
is the only meeting and so it might take
two hours it might take six but for that
to occur period of time there were
northern meetings in fact for me being a
non coder my number one job was to shut
the [__] up because I could create a
problem right
we're busy working we have this written
spec everyone knows what they're doing
if I have some brilliant idea during
that two weeks right that'll throw the
whole thing into chaos
suddenly the written specs not important
we're back to the drawing boards or
we're changing things Yeti ID Etta what
I had to realize is that every two weeks
we do this over again so for that
burning idea just [__] wait two weeks
and we're gonna have the meeting again
and then we can get it in and turns out
you're burning ideas probably wrong so
it's totally fine to wait two weeks to
try to kiss people do something wrong is
totally fun as opposed to like having
this cadence meant every two weeks we
had success every two weeks if we built
what we said we were gonna build we felt
good and then that cadence meant that
we'd go into the next cycle and do even
more this cadence is extremely important
because it's going to take you guys a
long time to find product market fit
maybe trying a lot of things we
iterating a lot and if that process
doesn't feel fun you're getting very
frustrated
this made the process feel fun because
we had goals and accomplish them versus
iterate a lot of YC companies a lot of
founders in general will tell me our
thing isn't working it's been two months
it's time to pivot when I think about
that statement it blows my mind right
you're building a new product for a
customer who might not have ever used
the product before you're oftentimes
exploring a problem that you only know
to some degree or you've only
experienced it personally what makes you
think two months is enough time to know
whether you figured something out what
impressive thing only took two months to
build so if you're not thinking that the
process of coming up with a solution for
this problem is probably the more like a
two-year process you're doing it wrong
if you are unsatisfied with significant
progress in under two years you're
probably doing it wrong it's going to
take time you're doing something hard if
it was really easy someone else would
have done it so I define pivot as
changing the customer or changing the
problem this should be rare this should
happen infrequently many times this
means you should start a new company i
define iterate as changing the solution
it turns out you had the right customer
you had the right problem your MVP was
shitty and it didn't work
we need a new solution it turns out
maybe your MVP was great but it didn't
solve the problem with a new solution it
turns out you showed the product to your
customers and they didn't want to use it
even though they have burning problems
we need a new solution often times I see
this in Reverse people think solution
first and when cut the customers they
thought didn't like their product they
try to find some other random customer
who does he might even have a completely
different problem and they tried
shopping around their solution because
they think their solution is the genius
part I think the problem is the genius
part I think identifying a problem that
other people haven't figured out is
worth working on is the genius part
right Facebook wasn't first a social
networking and Google wasn't first a
search engines their genius was
understanding that the people who came
before them hadn't solved the problem
and if they could solve the problem
better they'd built huge companies their
genius wasn't oh we built this cool
thing let's just figure out who might
want to use it wrapping up a little bit
here I always tell the story about fake
Steve Jobs versus real Steve Jobs a lot
of people think that Steve Jobs is this
person they should emulate but they have
a false picture in their heads of what
Steve Jobs was they think that like he
dreamed perfect ideas out of his head
and into the world and what's funny is
that I think often times people look at
the iPhone as perfect example of this
but they look at their iPhone today your
iPhone today is [__] magical the
first iPhone sucked in almost every way
and they don't realize that Steve Jobs
wasn't somebody who
was just not iterating who just imagine
your perfection minute one Steve Jobs
was iterating at every step so I like to
remind people what the first iPhone did
first iPhone no 3G back when 3G was a
standard feature so you have this great
internet browser but you can only use it
on edge which means it [__] sucks
right one carrier oh you don't have this
carrier sorry switch carriers figure
that out
horrible battery life screen cracked all
the time
no App Store you can't even download
other apps that was the first iPhone
everyone forgets that iPhone so if you
are the person in your company who is
being fake Steve Jobs is saying the
product has to be this way because what
I said [__] the customers [__] everyone
else [__] you make the product the way I
want it to be you're being fake Steve
Jobs real Steve Jobs released a shitty
MVP that was revolutionary but still
fairly shitty and every year iterated it
until you have the thing in your pocket
right now which is pretty damn good real
Steve Jobs iterates and talks to
customers fake Steve Jobs just dreams
and creates art don't be fake Steve Jobs
okay so with all this I want to go back
to the beginning what I said the
beginning still holds justin.tv the only
reason why I actually even know any of
these rules is because we broke all of
them the one thing that justin.tv and
twitch had was a really strong technical
team with high ego in the product and lo
burn when we started figuring things out
with twitch it was very interesting
gamers had been on our product the whole
time gamers had been streaming on
justin.tv since almost the beginning at
any given time there were twenty percent
of our traffic for years we ignored them
we ignored them we ignored them we
ignored them ignored them they still use
the product we didn't build features for
them they still use the product they
must been pretty [__] desperate
because they still use the product year
after year the number one thing that
changed when we started working on
twitch
we started talking to them and what's
weird was it's not like we were talking
to other users and the only reason we
didn't talk to any users we had this
like crazy part development cycles we
couldn't do that with talking users too
so what we did in the beginning was we
literally just sat down with these
gamers and we said what did you want and
what's funny is we didn't build them
anything very special they were like oh
like lag socks or the couple they wanted
like little things what was great about
it was they realized we were now going
to build something for them and no one
on the internet was building things for
these gamers and they realized that when
we said we're gonna build something it
came out when was the last time that you
talked to someone building a product
that you like and you said can you do
this and they did it was last time you
suggested a feature to mark at Facebook
and then the feature came out never like
it's one of the magical things you can
deliver as a startup is you can talk to
a passionate user and then you can build
what they want and then you can say here
it is and they will fall in love with
you even if those features are
relatively mundane because let's switch
today chat on the right video on the
left the same product what was great
about this process was by talking to
them they realized that we were on their
side we realized they were building
something for them so they tell their
friends that was the major change if we
didn't have the technical team if we
weren't sheep if our ego wasn't involved
I never would have gotten to that point
and if you look at the history of
justin.tv in the first five years it
went from being worth nothing to being
worth about twenty four million dollars
in the next three years it went being
worth twenty four million dollars
touring worth a billion like that's what
software can do when you when you hit
the right customer let's do a couple
questions in the back
so you've mentioned that product so the
question is put it more generally should
you be going free if your final idea for
a product is to be free what I would say
is this if your users are users who you
never plan to charge then it's totally
fine free to be free but if you do plan
to charge them in some way it's really
helpful to charge them as soon as
possible because you want to know
whether or not they're willing to pay
and certainly if their business depends
on it it's especially helpful to charge
them so that's the measure that I would
use and they're all kinds of little
tweaks and and so and so forth but at a
high level do you ever plan to charge
them I charge them if you never plan to
charge them you can plan to monetize
based on ads which is really usually the
way that you never plan charges you can
monetize with ads if you're not going to
monetize with ads you probably should
start charging them all right next
question
revenue if you're metric if your KPI is
metric do that if your KPI is revenue
and the number is zero should you still
be tracking that as your top-line KPI
the short answer is yes you should be
depressed looking at that number every
week too but that's that's the answer
now let's be clear like I said with
Socialcam right there are contributing
numbers to that right and so whereas
like DEA use was our top-line metric
right we also the things we thought
contributed to that new content new
users retained users those numbers we
can move so if you're in a sales type
business your KPI number one revenue if
it's zero that should [__] you in face
zero zero zero horrible but then you
should ask yourself maybe your three
other metrics are how many conversations
did we have this week how many people
are in contracting how people aren't
onboarding right and those can be your
three numbers that will if those numbers
move you expect the revenue number to
move and they can keep you motivated but
your your top-line KPIs no [__] like
absolute no [__] good we're a
hardware company pre-launch and so our
users our target market experience our
problem five to nine hundred times a day
and the intensity is can we pay our rent
or not but we'd like to offer pre-sales
as a way of getting the product to
market do you guys have any tips on
doing that do we have any tips on
pre-sales what I would say is that there
are many many tips on pre-sales I would
email some founders who've done it
before that's one of my best tip is to
email them and ask them what they did
the number one mistake I see with
pre-sales is discounting the number one
mistake is that basically especially
hardware founders will misunderstand how
much they need to charge so they don't
lose money and so their presale becomes
their death so I'd avoid that all right
two more quickly and the way back what
was the hardest part of having a slow
burn well we were young so it wasn't
hard at all we were living like we lived
in dorms I think it's a lot harder now
right I've got a kid I got a wife got an
apartment got a car it'd be really hard
now and so I think really the hard part
about slow-burn is can you adjust your
lifestyle if you've already leveled it
up and if you haven't leveled up your
lifestyle yet and you're still working
you know if you're young and you're
still working at a company that's paying
you well not leveling up your wife style
is a big way to stay ready to do a
startup adding on the mortgages and the
cars and the vacations makes it a lot
harder I just know a lot of people who
never could come back from that
absolutely
her back going from beta how do you go
from beta to early MVP I don't really
know what those distinctions are like
all I know is are people using your
product yes no like if people are not
using your product get to the point
where people are using your product
extremely quickly once people are using
your product there's all different
labels for it beta pre-launch alpha blah
blah who cares right it's just that's
the dividing line like are people using
a product the next question is are you
actually solving their problem that's
the next question not like are we
following this line of launching things
most YC companies will launch many many
many many times so that progression
isn't really that important are people
using your product great BAM
you're launched congratulations call
whatever you want all right this is a
great question and I have I'll have an
unsatisfying answer so the question is
basically how do we figure out what to
build next here's my answer the reason
why you have a part development cycle is
that you can work on multiple things
usually there isn't a right answer
usually all of the things that you want
to build won't work so what you need to
do is you need to create a process in
your company to build things quickly so
that you can actually see whether
they're work or not and then you can
iterate them from there so it's far more
important to have attack tactically
talented team that can build MVPs
quickly in a non frustrating way and
then measure the results than it is to
be
a super genius who can imagine what's
going to happen in the future without
actually knowing now I'm the big picture
you have to have that imagination for
your vision for where it's gonna be ten
years now you have to have that
imagination for the little technical
like tactical move in the next three
months like it's really hard to nail
those if you have a process that can rip
out things quickly and then only iterate
the things that are working that'll
serve you far better our mistake was
that at justin.tv
it was thinking every time we've got the
home run let's only swing for home runs
and of course it would take three months
to do it because we got to make it
perfect right and then the whole spike
spiral of death alright um the last
thing I'll say is my email address is
Michael at Y Combinator comm strangely I
tell people that I answer every email
and people mostly don't believe me and
the ones who do email me and I reply and
so everyone I talk to you and everyone
online there's really only two
categories of people the people who
don't believe me in which case great
continue your lives and the people who
will believe me and if you need help
they'll email and I will try to help you
the best I can
it's really that simple you don't need
to have networked with me Y Combinator
is fairly easy to spell and so is
Michael so you should be able to figure
that out
thank you
[Applause]
you